and Adam Karski joins me right now Adam
what a timely book it's hard to think of
a more timely book because really our
world right now is being shaped by kind
of two outbreaks there's the outbreak of
the virus corona virus and also the
outbreak of misinformation and political
information surrounding it and it's all
converging around the face mask if you
help us understand why something as
simple as a face covering has become so
controversial I think one of the
elements is it was it was uncertainty
around you know what the virus was what
the virus was doing and it's only from a
scientific point of view if you have
that uncertainty very kind of confident
new information will come in to fill it
and often that that information will
have some some issues and we'll have
some rumors I think now though we are
seeing a lot of things really kind of
play into those two those kind of
debates and you know unfortunately these
kind of situations where there there is
uncertainty and then people want
something to kind of latch on to that's
where you know people who perhaps
manipulating or putting disruptive
stories into the mix you know really
confide so why does misinformation which
is so attractive when you find it online
you want to share it right away
why does it catch fire and now that it
has caught fire how do you stop it why
do you how do you counteract it there's
a couple of features which almost train
us to to value mr. information and
that's you can trace that right back to
the kind of fundamental human properties
that we value information is new because
we think it's going to tell us and we
didn't know before so by definition of
something's false it's going to be
information that we haven't come across
there's also evidence the information
that can trigger quite fundamental
emotions or things that anger disgust
you know really can confer than
information that perhaps it doesn't
stimulate that kind of a response I
think one of the main things to be aware
of is just that that process of how
these things work that often when we see
some online angers us you know we want
to engage with it and reply but all
you're doing is getting those AMP
there's algorithms to amplify it and
actually help that contagion yeah you're
in the forecasting business
professionally for pandemics the the the
corona virus has been challenging to
forecast in America in particular
we've seen our graphics look very
different from those in Europe what is
it about this country that makes it
challenging for people in your line of
work I think one of the huge challenges
is just how quickly your behavior and
policies change during just epidemic you
know I think most of us are familiar
with things like weather forecasting and
obviously if you're pessimistic about
the weather that won't change what the
weather does but epidemics you know if
situation data comes in that suggests
we've got a problem and people change
behavior if you know if governors and
states change their policies you're
gonna see a very different outbreak
because of it so I think really trying
to work out exactly what cases will look
like in different areas in two three
months time is incredibly difficult but
there is there something about America
itself that makes it difficult to
forecast I I feel as though the virus
has brought out some of the best and
worst qualities of us as a country and
one of those qualities being
independents a certain skepticism and
unwillingness to listen to received
wisdom can you factor that in when
you're looking at how this is gonna grow
or not grow I think it's there's day two
emerging on kind of how people respond
to us I think early on is its enormous
ly challenging because we just haven't
shot populations down on this scale
really since the 1918 flu but I think
that issue of contrast independence is
an important one if you look at Asian
countries you know in Taiwan that
putting very strict quarantine you
almost cover electronic fences in Korea
having access to credit card data to do
contact tracing and that's not been
implemented in other countries in the
same way because I think there are you
know we focus on individual freedoms and
then it's much harder to in some cases
but persuade people to adhere to what
really quite disruptive measures if you
talk about the lockdowns were game
people stay at home you know that's a
big disruption to daily life could you
peer into the future for us and tell me
how does this end I think really we're
looking for situation we've got a
vaccine because at the moment the way
the countries are keeping it under
control or keeping the health systems
being overwhelmed is by this incredibly
disruptive social distancing you know
some countries have got it down locally
places like New Zealand but then
obviously have to keep borders really
restricted to prevent cases coming in so
I think ultimately we want a situation
where there's enough immunity within the
population the
we don't have to do all these really
disruptive changes trial routine
I think getting there without a vaccine
and avoiding a situation like New York
or Italy is gonna be very difficult yeah
and when a vaccine arrives there's a
question of how quickly people will take
it so do you have a sense of when a
demand in the final 30 seconds here
I think optimistically if we can have
some very next year I think we have to
be aware that it might not be a perfect
vaccine and as you say it might not be
one that everyone takes up straightaway
yeah and then we'll be back in the
situation we are in now with a double
outbreak the virus and then
misinformation around things related to
the virus including a vaccine Adam
kuchar's key thank you very much the
book rules of contagion is on sale right
now it'll help you understand your world